it's Friday busy week
notable quotables even if you leave the
book still thinking I'm an idiot you
realize I'm actually kind of an honest
idiot any Republican senator that hasn't
been conflicted over the presidency is
either comatose or pretty useless four
months five minutes they're still here
I've been gone for a year I'm like a
break up he can't get over he wakes up
in the morning and tweaks advance a
thumbs down to Mike Pompeo is a middle
finger to the American people who voted
for Donald Trump if the meeting when I'm
there is not fruitful I will
respectfully leave the meeting quote
with all due respect I don't get
confused brace brace brace pray God put
us all on that plane for a reason we
don't know why it's very disappointing
for the present Trump pick has gone this
direction you want to deport an
undocumented person start with me run
Eric run stuff we got to talk to my wife
about that one I can't think less
attractive when there is a speaker's
race I'm certainly open to it
the end of a beautiful life no more
saying what's on my mind although it was
fun at the time all in one week amazing